Joy Behar
and the cackling hands at the view are
somewhat impressed by one of the latest
nominees for the presidency that would
be Nikki Haley
part of the Invasion of the Body
Snatchers you know there are these there
are these politicians on the right who
now have become like mentally crazy you
know but our problem is that you know
Not only was she a big Trump supporter
and like she's an election denial too
isn't she at one point at one point but
she changed she flip-flopped on that
yeah but she also backed Herschel Walker
one of the worst candidates we've ever
had I mean second only May or second
only to George Santos maybe yeah you
know and that was terrifying actually
that you did that so I mean she's going
to election to hires one I'm not sure
she's an election denier I would check
on that
okay there you go this is a warning to
all the other GOP candidates
it doesn't matter how much they like you
it doesn't matter how much you do to try
to earn some favor with the liberal
press they will always turn on you
that phrase that Joy Behar said at the
beginning it's like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers this is what you always hear
sometimes for some of the Republicans
who the libs like or at least pretend to
like while those Republicans are serving
their purposes saying certain liberal
things attacking certain conservative
candidates
the moment that you pose any kind of
threat to them
they will say oh this person's totally
changed this person's totally the libs
love Mitt Romney now because Mitt
Romney's a big squish and he he parrots
their talking points
then the libs loved Mitt Romney
before 2008
after he was governor of Massachusetts
before he was a republican nominee
back when he was taking on some of the
other Republicans to do that the libs
really liked him and then he got the
nomination for the GOP and then he posed
a threat to Barack Obama and then he was
a monster he was he was Patrick Bateman
he was trying to kill gay boys in high
school do you remember that thing they
said he cut the hair of a homosexual
teenager or something oh and the dog he
tried to torture his dog on the family
car and they'll just and that's what
they're doing now to Nikki Haley
who Nikki Haley
was a somewhat Centrist kind of governor
in South Carolina then she worked for
the Trump Administration but she managed
to have decent support among the
moderates and also among Trump
supporters
then she came out against Trump after
the administration after January 6th and
then she but then she defended Trump
again and so she's she's
done actually a relatively decent job of
maintaining some kind of support
uh in different quarters but not but not
very intense support which is why you're
not seeing her jump up in the polls to
the position of Iran DeSantis or Donald
Trump right now
but she should be one of the more
acceptable people to the view if for no
other reason that that she is a woman
and the view is a show about empowering
women and yet
they see Nikki Haley she's running to be
the GOP nominee okay she's dead to us
she's crazy it's Invasion of the Body
Snatchers no more strange no respect
George Santos
Jared Santos our favorite Republican is
back in the news
he was charged with a dog-related theft
in 2017 this according to the Washington
Examiner
representative George Santos was found
to have been charged with theft related
to Amish dog breeders
in 2017.
are the Amish known for I know they're
known for their cabinets and their Barns
and their I didn't know they were known
for dog breeding the charges were
dropped though and his record was
expunged
a lawyer friend of Santos
who helped him with the charge told
Politico about the revelation
it was then confirmed by representative
from York County district court in
Pennsylvania
uh he was charged with theft by
deception but he beat the charge and had
that record expunged he claimed his
checkbook had been stolen and that the
fifteen thousand one hundred twenty five
dollars in checks were not written by
him but now some people say he was lying
and after the checks were addressed to
the Amish dog breeders Santos held a
large adoption event with his animal
rescue charity friends of pets United at
the Staten Island pet store pet Oasis
and and
I don't know and I don't know and I
don't and I don't really care I've said
it before about George Santos
George Santos to me his political
success is like a bad joke
a bad joke starts out
a little tiny bit funny
and then the more you tell it it becomes
much much less funny
but then paradoxically the more you tell
it
be much much much much much funnier it
becomes
that's how I feel about Santos Santos
gets elected you say hey all right we
got a republican here elected in New
York we got a razor thin majority
already this is this is cool he's got
he's obviously a squish but you know
whatever it's fine that's fine oh um
overall net positive and then you find
out oh he lied about his education oh
that's good no he's a liar that's too
bad only lied about his employment
history oh that's too bad oh and he he
might not even be a gay guy
he might have he might have been married
to a woman in it which I guess is more
traditional I guess that's kind of a
maybe that ticks him up a little but
then he got divorced and I was
pretending to be a gay guy and or he
maybe is I don't know and oh and he lied
about his uh criminal record maybe oh
and he lied about his political
positions oh and he lied about okay
we're back it's fine and he might be
under indictment in Brazil oh this is
getting funnier again oh and he lied
about Amish dog breeding and okay this
is really
really funny at this point
there isn't pretty much nothing that
George Santos could do
that would make me demand that he
resigned because it's all out there and
this is by the way
probably the main argument for Trump in
2024. the main argument against Trump in
2024 is that he's got so much baggage
and there are lots of people who just
don't like him and he turns a lot of
people off and that's that
strong argument
but the argument for Trump in 2024 is
also he's got so much baggage
and we know about it and it's all out
there and they throw in the kitchen sink
at him and they've made up a bunch of
stuff about them and it's been proven to
have been made up about him and
it is what it is for the other
candidates
we don't know how much real baggage
they've got we don't know
what new baggage the libs are going to
invent about them
we don't know how resilient they're
going to be in the face of that
I am real some people think that I'm
pushing Trump and that I've actually
made a decision I'm endorsing Trump in
2020. that is not the case I am it might
seem more that way when I talk about it
because I haven't picked one of the
other candidates to go sign up on the
campaign for I am just trying to call it
like I see it okay I'm not saying one of
these two options is better than the
other the case for or against Trump the
only point I'm making is it's the same
case
it's the same argument and you're seeing
it at an extreme degree in George Santos
George Santos is not going to really be
pressured to step down the more that the
the Press attack him actually the more
that it helps him
the more that you see those press
squabbles all around him screaming
yelling it makes Republicans like him
more even if Republicans look at him
they say there's like almost nothing
about you that I like as a politician
you're pretty much a squish you you're
obviously a liar
you can't be trusted what's it but
the fact that the the libs are gunning
form so much it will increase his
support
and you will see similar phenomena play
out at the presidential level as well
the rest of the show continues now it's
work Wednesday we have got
uh some really great woke content that
producer Ben Davies insists that I react
to he thinks that will scandalize me he
thinks and it will shock me very little
shocks me anymore so we'll see about
that become a member right now daily
wire.com Knowles use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
thank you